my question was what evidence do we have
outside of the sacred texts that the
sacred texts are even the word of god in
other words wars have been predicted for
a very long time within and outside of
religious texts conflict and the rise
and fall of nations has been predicted
my question was a different one
unfortunately though
we're just out of time we're just out of
time
it was an illogical question you asked
well you don't you find it illogical
because there's no such proof next and
that's illogical so i've been doing
radio for for 20 years and i know how
all this works and i i can see your
agenda but well it's not an agenda i am
a search if if we are to actually
explore
evidence from a scientific perspective
you've presented none you've cited
deuteronomy as proof of a later book
listen carl i i'm sorry i i know because
you know this time of course carl we had
we agreed to 10 minutes we've done 13.
i'm you're welcome back literally any
time i am not trying to shut down the
conversation